it wasn't the wasn't the original plan
for the rest of the show but
it wasn't had some other sometimes you
gotta call an audible yeah
it's lady man she's my new favorite
so
she made this video
that toilet's disgusting just showing
you
one of the nicest places in san san
point
bathroom the cedar bridge
cedar street bridge one of the only two
in the world allegedly by the way it's
not even the the [ __ ] in the toilet and
all that which is gross enough look at
the seat
because the seat is that's by the way
that's not like somebody pissed on the
seat that is gross
that's that is a deeply stained
toilet seat
[Laughter]
and i've [ __ ] in some questionable
bathrooms but
by the way sorry guys if you're eating
lunch so that was a quick 27 minutes
video boy who eats lunch at four o'clock
and then five o'clock
it's really bad i'm not in the best
of uh i'm in good health
in most ways because i've been
detoxing and fasting for like
four years now i mean she hasn't eaten
in
four years that you should probably get
some food and
i've heard that that's not good i've
always i heard that if you go
like five years without eating you die
yeah she probably gets something in you
oh and
detoxed along the way but i
started on a path to uh
really cleanse my body of a lot of
things
and there's still something i need
one is not addressing so that tells me
he doesn't know what's going on
he really doesn't know i thought he was
in a awakening vedras
a what an awakening vedros
what is that is that a is that a
is that a warrior class and wow an
awakening veterans no it's actually the
new dlc they're working on
okay it'll be a new class in the new dlc
okay so if you're going to be an
awakening veteran i'll tank for you
yeah it's a combination of like okay
bard and also a healer
got it got it got it got it and he
probably is he just
isn't there yet
she's i think she's just nodding off
that is i'm sorry my voice is so
rough and everything he beats me
in this car i'm trying to figure out
what
she's watering i haven't been eating
very well
so i'm almost down to 100 pounds
lady eat um it's not very easy
to live on the road for anybody let
alone a woman
let alone a 69 year old woman
but like maybe then
don't do all of this did you did you not
hear that he's in a waking vegemite
and look i there's gonna be people that
go like you know this is wrong i feel
bad or whatever but i don't feel bad
especially for white women because
let me use this analogy being a white
woman
is like being on the holodeck of a star
trek vessel
right like all of us have to just like
live our lives live with the
consequences of our actions
have accountability pay for our own
mistakes
white women can in any point call a
timeout
and go i want to turn off the holodeck
now i want i want a new apartment i want
i want to start over i need help and
immediately everybody just blows the
whistle they get they get unlimited
timeouts
you know imagine if one football team in
the super bowl got unlimited timeouts
yeah that's what the white woman thing
is she's 69 year old emaciated white
woman
she could walk in right now into any
public services office and go
i need help i'm crazy and they will give
her anything she needs
so i want to feel bad but at the same
time
white women live in the holodeck not the
real world
i'd like to know who would have the
[ __ ] courage to do what i've done
probably not even a 50 year old
i mean i've played oregon trail yeah i
could drive to idaho
i just would prefer not to because it's
idaho
when you get there you're like well this
is this was pretty
this is it's probably anticlimactic
30 year old owen couldn't do it owen
could not do what i'm doing
why why would he want to
way more [ __ ] courage and i ain't
afraid to say that
because i know it's true
i
here's an example of something i did
just to show my daughter
she has a kid she has a kid
yeah but she's 69. nice
so it's not we're talking about a grown
daughter and that means that this grown
daughter
also wants nothing to do with this woman
again going back to the point
you want to kind of feel bad but at the
same time it's like when you see a
homeless person
who's on drugs and they have no teeth
and they're begging for like 50 cents
and people go oh that's so sad so sad
all those poor
that poor guy and you go nobody's entire
f
like social group their entire family
everyone in their life everyone doesn't
abandon you and let you live
they've probably tried really hard i
would agree with that
mom please come back mom plea and she's
probably ignoring them because
she's she thinks owens is is is an
awakened draugr
and whatever i'm i think and and and she
thinks he's gonna save him
how fearless i am
i walked across four lanes of moving
traffic
yeah i mean i played frogger nice
ah it's not that hard lady it's really
i mean in later levels it is the logs
are the difficult part
really if you think about it if you
crossed one time that means you made it
to level two
i wouldn't exactly start bragging
it didn't get touched
so wait wait she she says lady you're
gonna get yourself hurt
she walked across lanes of highways and
didn't get touched because of her
magical powers which she's insinuating
am i correct yeah no
it's you walked across four lanes of
highway in idaho during a pandemic
i'm pretty sure you could honestly in
an interstate highway in idaho right now
during covid i'm pretty sure you could
curl up and take a nap
and probably not get hit by a car do
that
just do that alone let alone take a trip
a nine ten hour trip however long it was
look at this that light coming up isn't
that nice it's called the sun
it comes up every morning it's and it's
annoying i get it yeah
especially when you're up doing coke all
night and you're like god damn it can't
you take a day off i get it lady but
it's just the sun
buy a park
day or [ __ ] whatever
i was staying at the grabbler inns
it's the parroting of the the language
and everything
[Music]
[ __ ] grabblers that
[ __ ] walked in my room without
knocking when i was naked
and i found out he does it to all to
other women
he won't do it to a man could you
imagine him doing it to
owen big boy uh it's happened to me
before it's happened to me too
it's annoying and you definitely go to
the front desk and make a scene
hey look they walked in when i was
seeing it but i've had that hat before
i've i've been almost naked
oh sorry and i'm like jesus christ lady
but i've never been like
i bet they're doing that to all the sexy
boys
no you just go look man maybe you got to
retrain these people or whatever
tell them to [ __ ] knock please
because the worst is when when they do
the the knock as they open
yeah well then why not give us a point
yeah
oh and beg bear you guys can go back
all you people who think i'm lying fair
i got to be objective here beg bear is
pretty funny back bear's pretty good
back bears i get but i have a feeling
you didn't make that one up you probably
got that from other circles
yeah back bear is kind of funny i think
i'm crazy or whatever the [ __ ]
most people are supporting me if you
read the comments
no lady you know what they're doing
they're not supporting you
they're edging you on because they they
want to see how far you'll go
crackers bear says this is so
embarrassing listen
don't come in here having a bear in your
name and act like all of a sudden you
discovered the concept of self-awareness
how dare you sir so you could go back on
my
videos for months ago months and months
ago
this lady's making us respectable bears
look like real
right now and read what i said there
you determine how honest of a person i
am
how innocent and pure he can't
say that he has said so many misleading
things
she's that's what i want to point out in
the last couple videos she's used a lot
of buzz words
that i would find very concerning yeah
uh pure purify
wrath like this there's certain
buzzwords
very elliot roger you know mad about
so he's misleading a lot of his own
followers you guys are too ignorant to
see it
but you were too ignorant to see it
until he didn't let you live in his home
yeah right like again this goes back to
that
all these people that do this [ __ ] these
people that develop these weird
fixations on the internet and then when
they don't get what they want
then all of a sudden it's he's a grifter
he's this he's lying he's doing this and
you're like but you loved him up until
he said i can't let you live in my home
you drove across the country for him man
or just too unintelligent
or both yeah no you have a smart one
right you're the smart one
living in your car in sandpoint idaho i
might say you're a real [ __ ]
sharp cookie you haven't seen all the
healing crystals she has so why don't
you back off before you make these rash
judgments
i refu i'm sorry but i refuse to be
called an idiot by a woman who's made it
almost
70 years old and her legacy is living
out of her car in idaho i would say
let's say that i was also living in my
car in idaho
i'm still 37 so even even if i was
parked next to you sleeping in my car
you still couldn't call me stupid or a
loser because i still have like
32 more years to try to catch up to you
i still have almost my entire life span
to live again to try to not be living in
that car in sandpoint idaho
cop did let me stay here he told me it's
not
i should be over at the friggin walmart
park
parking lot that freaking place is evil
stay away from walmarts but what about
when the when
they have like sales i don't think
walmart's your biggest concern here lady
what about okay lady how about this what
about just on black friday
because they do have some cool things on
black friday yeah
friday i won't go to walmart anymore but
let me go once a year when they have
like the
[ __ ] giant flat screens for like 28
bucks you know what i mean
you know what you get every black friday
at walmart assaulted
[Laughter]
which is why they call it that yes
most people are so addicted to their
lifestyle and their appetites
that's what's going to bring them down
why are you just realizing all of this
including owen because he is ignorant of
what is going on
there are some things i wanted to say to
him
that i could not say in a letter and
said i wouldn't say it in a letter
what could you possibly do you have some
sort of truth about life
but here's the thing right let's pretend
that you're a complete stranger right
now
and you're approaching me at [ __ ]
some store and you're like i know you
from the internet
and you want to just like here tell me
you've got something really important
you want to tell me
oh mike i have something very important
i need to tell you look man no offense i
don't really know you or anything
and i don't like i don't owe you that
but i've known you for 12 years and
we've done a show together i don't
oh i'm supposed to be a character i'm
sorry he's a terrible actor i apologize
they've heard the commercials they
wanted royce to be in movies
and it's just he's literally homer
simpson in the interrogation scene
i think he's talking to you
and i'm not going to say it now
but he has some something
is going to happen mark my
words that's the creepy stuff you were
mentioning
there that's [ __ ] scary man i've
never
and i probably could have with certain
people
but i've never actually contacted law
enforcement
about some of the weirdos that come
after me but
if if there was a video going around
with
wrath purification and a day of is
coming i would go
hey look could you at least go talk to
the guy like i don't you know what i
mean i'm usually not scared
but i'm starting to get scared
something is going to happen does
anybody know
sloan bella i mean
i don't know if you maybe can you hum a
few bars did she
open up for lizzo you might be right
yeah
the la psychic oh who helped police
solve cases and everything
yeah that was turned out to be a big
farce yeah no no i remember that and
then she had the black partner and it
was like they
started getting in all these wacky high
jinks are you talking about psych
the usa usa show yeah they solved all
the crimes and then he fell in love with
that girl who was kind of cute but no
no i was usa some reason she was cuter
outside of the show but when in the show
they made her less cute for some reason
and then they did a guest appearance on
raw
oh god whose
own son who they they
the controllers knew was the person
she loved the most in the world
and just before i go on owen has
broadcast that
amy is the most important person
to him which is that inappropriate
that's his wife yeah is that supposed to
be shocking supposed to be
that's not a big deal now they
know who to target if you get what i
mean
lady who's they because i feel like they
is you i feel like
they is just you
this is getting really creepy man yeah
this is so i'm not going to say anything
more on that unless you want to talk in
person about it owen
why would you have this person anywhere
near your family
and and you know still people that are
saying this is all owen's fault
and i'm sorry it's not he he's it's like
i said yesterday
does he have a role that he played in
this
yes is there things he could have done
differently to avoid these kind of
things from happening
yes but nobody
and i mean nobody should have to deal
with
crazy people like they're showing up and
scaring their family and wife and kids
i'm sorry you you're never going i
despise owen benjamin
you're never going to convince me that
he his wife and his children
deserve this i there's no you just can't
sell me on that i'm sorry
i am out to protect you and your family
i am not stalking you you have always
been behind me
i was at the post office first chris
razzie on plot twist
he banged this old bag on the
impractical joker screws
oh boy very obscure reference but very
funny
so who's stalking who if anybody's
stalking anybody
which i am not claiming you're doing
and i am not either a lot of people
interested in this as you can see the
video i made
has gone like to 1.2
k why would i get
so many views if do you want to take
this one you want me to take this one
uh did you want to no but you can if you
want i mean
it's fine i can't answer that question
ma'am but i think i i could probably
imagine some i have some theories as to
maybe why but
i don't nothing concrete i don't know
we'll circle back get back to you
oh [ __ ] did we knock over a can of
gasoline next to the fire accidentally
if this was not real it's like me and
royce pulled up
closer to a fire to get good footage of
it but we knocked into a can of gasoline
and it just dumped into the brush fire
we're like
back up back up let's just pull out here
let's just go let's just go
[Laughter]
my struggle wasn't real and if your
[ __ ]
wasn't real i want you to stop
saying some of the things you're saying
i told you that in the letters okay but
it doesn't work that way
that's not how life works lady then it's
not how it
works listen owen i want you to stop
saying some of the things you're saying
or your day of reckoning is coming
look i want elon musk to stop affecting
the stock market and bitcoin but i mean
i can't make the guy yeah and have i
thought about if i fantasized about
him before sure but i haven't made 25
minute videos
committing to the thought he didn't
drive to austin yeah
i just some days i punch a wall and i go
god i want a
son of a [ __ ] and then i go and i'd go
on about my day
that you're going to have a lot of
retracting to do if you're so honest
i believed in you i still do
but you are too dumbed down to even
recognize it
as you make fun of everybody else that's
so dumb
one step too far says guys this is my
mom she needs to be put down
okay well then i'm sorry when your own
when your own son is like look man do
what you got to do
at this point i feel like you know
she'll finally be at peace
make and all you can talk about is dicks
and penises and
[ __ ] okay go on i'm
i'm let's see where i want hey i'm gonna
let you keep going but watch yourself
look i get what you're saying lady you
know and does say a lot of sexy stuff
but what does that have to do with it
yeah
okay cool now i'm hard
let's get back to owen yeah great now
i'm sitting in a cold car in san point
idaho with a [ __ ] erection
thanks a lot yeah this is great am i
supposed to jerk off in that disgusting
toilet yeah and
exactly i don't even want to aim my dick
at that thing three feet away
and now what now i'm hungry and now the
only thing that's open isn't arby's or
her loves
come on man it's been a tough day
yeah loves is where [ __ ] truckers
have sex yes
come on stop focusing on
when there's real [ __ ] wow
wow that was a real hard f too that was
a hard f she was not she was very
lady disavow nothing in the world and
you want to still be mr entertainer
mr popularity mr i'm too good for my
[ __ ] fans
i was gonna start singing the
entertainer but it's like the worst
billy joel song and i can't even
remember the words
something like i am the entertainer
still mr hollywood please
stop it i know you're going to be
listening to these videos
hollywood idaho
look say what you want about oh and mr
hollywood and all that [ __ ] but
and he is a grifter and he has ripped
off people and he's built a cult but
i wouldn't exactly say he hasn't
committed to the bit
i mean the guy has to squeeze milk uh
goat nipples to get milk
i'd say that's committing to the bit at
that point right yeah would everybody
else
and not you yes scaredy cat
i'm calling you a coward yeah i'm
calling you a coward
and i don't usually call people names
but you're showing so much cowardice
i can't help myself need to get your
[ __ ] attention somehow
to prevent what's going to happen
another case of very weird things
this is this is dorothy in the chat says
and
i'm moving out
[Laughter]
remember that stalking owen benjamin
will give you a heart attack
you want to know by now oh
[ __ ] you know i'm
psychic obviously
i have abilities that you're not aware
of she could move things with her mind
did she claim that well in a roundabout
way
she doesn't specifically yes she can
she's always the most useless skill i'm
always like oh wow cool we're gonna ruin
silverware
she's related to geller
if you would read those ringing cedars
books i sent you
and return my picture too that is pretty
[ __ ] rude that you won't acknowledge
me
and now i'm asking to send my picture
back to me
that was taped in one of the book
where's he gonna mail it to lady your
car
two walmart parking lots
two cat goddess a queen bee
care of walmart parking lot of
anesthesia
that i sent you from my collection that
my daughter gave me for mother's day
that i've read like three times already
maybe you want to
read them and find out some stuff too
that's unself-published not through any
system or any i don't read any books
that anybody puts out
there has not been any new ideas until
anesthetic came along
and i could read who is anesthesia but
i'm
in the dark some i really
sounds like a black strippers name
excerpt up there there's a lot of people
that would be helped by these books
my friend just started reading them and
he's so excited
that it's just beyond words
i am so happy you seem to have plenty of
words he will grow so much from it
and he's already way beyond most people
he's even beyond you in
so many ways he's an astrologer he's
doing your natal chart
for me thank god because i was worrying
if it was mur because mercury was in
retrograde why owen was so crazy
for him too he wants to find out now
let me go through this
journey with you i've been here since
mid december right before christmas
and i was hoping that you would respond
to me i really thought you would
and i'm sitting here in idaho
and i'm getting frostbite on my toes
and i got kicked out of the days inn
for pooping too much the guy walked in
carrier situation that's what brought me
here
i was led divinely here oh okay i'm on a
mission
that most people from god she is she
just got copyright struck blues brothers
i undertake at 69 years old and
nice nice it's getting older yeah
it is but we have to i'm having problems
with my health because of this [ __ ]
nano i'm trying to kick out of me
like all my devices i got from my friend
in switzerland
i can't see i look i i'm with you lady
i'm siding with this lady now i don't
understand why owen benjamin didn't want
her living
in his home with his children yeah she
seems rational she seems nice
beautiful exceptional woman from what
i've seen
i wish i could see more of her she's got
more purity of heart no see people
keep saying the nano and so she what
happened was
okay she she
inserted an ipod nano into herself
during a sexual act years ago
and it became embedded in one of her ied
iuds or whatever
and it got stuck and it keeps playing
crazy town yeah and they can't they
can't
get the ipod nano out now unless they
rip oliver [ __ ] out with it
right so they just so she has a nano
inside her
and it's still and it's still playing
and you are and you are have issues with
women that you
are not addressing so please
do that okay work out your mommy issues
all men have them just like i have my
daddy issues my daddy abandoned you
no i would have never guessed i would
never think you have any kind of issues
my daddy wally left me
in newberry dad was a robot that used to
clean up trash
he was yes in the future
that's where the nanobots came from i
didn't know that you were a robot that
looked suspiciously like
e.t i was born in new york too
what are the odds of that wait till you
see i mean pretty high there's a lot of
people that are born there one of the
most well-populated regions in the world
frankly
all the connections and similarities in
our life
my brother died two years before you
were born
and i believe that you are him
reincarnated
boy
oh
[Music]
oh no
oh and look i know owen doesn't watch
the show but oh and if this message gets
to you
um i know you don't want to take advice
from
a guy like me but oh and if this woman
shows up on your property
[ __ ] shooter yeah dude don't even
play any [ __ ] games bro
if this person was talking like about
this about me and all these videos
for this many weeks and they showed up
to my apartment
there would be three hollow points in
that [ __ ] no questions
asked and i would go hey look man here's
the videos
you know what i mean and with our
sheriff where we live
i would just show any deputy one video
from youtube and go look and they'd go
yeah that's fine okay we'll get a guy
over here to scrape this up might be
a little bit while and that would be the
end of it if you believe in
reincarnation
you should be able to accept that
[Music]
so i'm going to stop here and i will put
out
more videos people are asking for more
and they want to talk about your natal
chart which has already shown up
as you have something to hide
you have something to hide what is that
and why are you so afraid
of a little old lady all right look you
know
i i want to just say this though it is
funny to watch this [ __ ]
but i i'm i am strongly urging
every single one of you in this
community to not engage this woman
and watch the videos and laughs yeah no
i agree i agree 100
don't comment don't edgar on don't put
ideas in her head don't
i am telling everyone right now do not
engage this woman we can watch and laugh
but
th this is some this is going to end
badly
this is going to end badly
jesus christ man